a year ago I was just starting out my
property journey to go from zero to
making this pretty much passively it's
crazy what sort of profit are you making
in your property business per month so
my rent to rent side making about 9 to
10 grand profit a month the deal Source
in 9k a month think you bit off more
than you could Chew in an area that you
weren't familiar with you didn't have
the experience now I bet you could take
that same property I actually make it
profitable it might cost me three grand
to make this place look nice it might
cost someone else 10 15 grand I wrote a
gold down I was like by the end of the
year I want to be making four grand
passive income of Double
Down Adam low thanks so much for coming
on win us on a Wednesday mate we've been
working together now for a year or two
yeah just over a year yeah and become
super close and it's been great seeing
your journey and seeing you you know
absolutely crush it on the business side
of thing so talk to me about how you got
into property because your background is
carpentry right yeah so how did you kind
of transition into property and what was
it that gave you that thirst and hunger
for property um well starters I always
wanted to be in property since I always
Young um I mean my family have enough
milon to property but I always kind of
just had this idea in my heads that this
is the kind of Route I wanted to go down
um obviously since leaving school I've
always done you know carpentry been in a
building game and I've been working on
you know multi-million pound houses so
I've seen you know kind of you know what
property can give you in life yeah
that's kind of just where I really
wanted to go really and also I know that
if I was to get into property myself I
could kind of link my building skills
with the
as well yeah yeah you know what a lot of
people that are in construction just
like there's always a bit of an appetite
I want to do this myself one day but
most people will just save save up money
save up money save up money and then
when they're in their 40s they'll buy
their first investment and then before
you know it they're in their 50s and 60s
and they and they're still working I
mean what sort of profit are you making
in your property business per month
split between the two so my rent to rent
side would probably making about n Grand
profit a month but 9 to 10 grand profit
a month and then the deal sourcing with
selling I'd say on average about three
Deals a month um you know some months
are higher than others um but on average
probably about three so about 9k a month
on deal cool so that's like close to 20
grand profit yeah that's amazing though
yeah that must feel surreal it's crazy
because literally a year ago I was just
starting out my property journey and I
didn't really know anything about
property at all so to go from zero to
you know making this pretty much
passively it's crazy and how old are you
uh 26 so you're young I mean not many 26
year olds didn't go to university no I
didn't go University you know straight
from from from from from a construction
background to making 29 month prop
property how does it does it feel does
it feel surreal yet or does it does it
kind of sunk in or it hasn't sunk in um
I mean I mean at the moment I'm not even
taking a wage from the property side of
things so most of my income is still
coming from my building side but so
you're living off of your day job yeah
and then you're reinvesting all the
proper so whatever money comes in from
the property side is just getting
reinvested makes sense you know we're
saving up for bigger deals on the
pipeline yeah and you got this little
block of apartments that you're in
negotiations with tell me about tell me
about that yeah so it's um a partner of
mine um it's a family member so we've
put an informal offer to buy a house and
basically to convert her house into two
flats and she's got quite a big um plot
of lands so around the house so we're
looking to build four flats on it we've
met up with the architect he's you know
he's got good things about it he says
you know it's likely that you'll get
accepted on planning for this because
there's other flats around the area um
but yeah hopefully by summer and that
will probably be financed I imagine
through your rent to rent deal sourcing
or you pull investors in no we pull in
investors as well a lot of our Rental
rent deals we actually get a private
Finance so a lot of people from the
academy actually so what we would tend
to do is we would ask for you know for
example 5 grand for a 10% return um and
a lot of people are actually open to
doing that why would they invest in one
of your deals and get 10% return when
they could do something themselves
what's the advantage do you like teach
them and bring them in on the deal or
are they just happy to just sit back do
nothing and make 10% passive yeah I mean
a lot of the investors that we work with
they're still very fresh to the game so
they would like to see you know they're
basically investing into us and we're sh
them basically how it goes start to
finish so they get to see it be part of
it almost like uh learning from inves
yeah exactly that you know if they ever
need a hand or any advice or things like
that then you know we're always on the
other end of the phone for them yeah so
when did you get your first rent to rent
and how did it come about first rent to
rent came in February
2022 what two years ago sorry 2023 oh
wow not that long ago yeah so now it's
February 2024 yeah yeah sorry yeah yeah
um so yeah February 2023 um our first sa
is one of my partners colleagues who
owns this property uh he found out what
we was doing and um his property was up
for rental and we obviously made an
offer told him what we was going to do
to it and you know everything like that
and you know we still got it now and
he's happy we're happy and it's a great
way to get into the game to find someone
that you actually know has got a
property because I think that your first
property is always your hardest
generally 100% when you've got one and
you can use it as a case study then you
can approach agents and you can approach
landlords that you don't know C people
you say look I've got this property here
here's what we do with it here's how it
works so that came from somebody like a
a bit of a mutual friend yeah I mean I
would say it was kind of handed to us
but previous to that we was on the phone
for four months straight making calls
just getting knows all the time um you
know we got we got a few yeses to go and
do viewings we go do the viewing and
then they changed their minds it came to
us at a very good time cuz within those
four months PR prior to that you know
we're still learning um but you know
once we actually took it on and we got
into the nitty-gritty of it it was you
were ready it was like a light bulb
moment yeah why do you think you were
getting so many nose were you not
confident or were you saying the site
wrong thing or what was going on I think
confidence was a huge factor of it I
mean before I joined the Academy I never
really used to make calls or sales calls
or anything like that cuz you know from
the building gu work my hands yeah so I
remember when I first on your live
training the rents of rent one you was
like all right everyone go out um make
some calls when you come back for lunch
I want I want to you know hear what was
happening I found some
leads and I see everyone else making
calls and um I typed in the number and I
was so nervous and I was just staring at
my phone about 10 minutes just trying to
make it cool to this landlord any I
pressed the call button phoned him and
said oh hi um looking to do a company
let he was like no no not interested go
away you waste my time and I was like
ouch yeah and I was just like what am I
doing yeah yeah but then you tried
performance after you been so after that
yeah I kept trying you just kept getting
Reed I kept trying I kept getting nose
but what I was doing because I created a
script but then every time I'd get a no
i' think okay maybe my scripts wrong I
tweak my script tweak my script you know
now now I'll get on the phone to a
landlord just pick up the phone talk to
him and it's fine do you think that it's
just tough when you get started or do
you think that you were a bit unlucky or
what happened I say a little bit of both
it is tough like nothing in life worth
having comes easy you know it's just
changing you know what you're used to to
learning something completely new I'd
love to hear a recording of that first
phone call bro I bet you were terrible
yeah I was um I remember I even sat in
my car and done it so no one could hear
yeah I was like I don't want anyone to
hear what I'm about to say you knew it
was going to be bad yeah but it's the
same as anything there isn't it like I
know we've been sparing a lot doing a
lot of boxing and I watched my first
sparring session and it was around
January February 2023 so around about
the same sort time you joined the
academy and I was like what was I doing
I looked terrible and it's like you
don't realize how bad you are at the
time I was like yeah man I'm doing good
but I think it's the same with making
calls to get deals if you've not done it
before you're going to be rubbish yeah
100% And if you're rubbish and
unconfident and you don't even believe
in yourself and you don't know what
you're doing then of course landlords
are going to not feel comfortable going
ahead with the business no 100% And it's
not until you actually look back and you
realize I've actually done quite well
over this past year and I've actually
improved quite a bit Yeah so your first
deal was through someone that you knew
were you nervous taking that on did you
feel like scared yes I was scared
because obviously for this first deal we
actually used our own money and you know
to put an investment in that we've you
know we've never invested in property in
our life yeah so it was like oh you know
what if we don't get any bookings or how
much did you have to put in initially we
put in 2,500 no deposit um the rent was
1600s so that was first month and then
900 on Furnishings did it work out it's
probably one of my best properties I've
got going at the moment how much profit
does that one property you make over
Christmas that made 2,300 pound net
profit jeez and this is Studio what
about like in a bad month like January
,200 that's incredible yeah really
interesting so that must have given you
confidence when that went live and then
it's like I know what I'm doing I've got
it systemized yeah I mean you say that
that property right there was like a
little Golden Nugget you know after that
we was like yeah you know we're going to
get loads of properties two months after
that we took on five rental SAS in
Bradfords and another one in East London
that's where we kind of thought these
Bradford ones a ain't for us I remember
that they they were horrible weren't
they yeah a lot of people want to hear
the the the failures as well as
successes we could sit here all day and
talk about how you're making 20 grand a
month and isn't it amazing but I really
want to spend some time talking about
some of the crap deals that you took on
and the problems so so talk me through
what happened in Bradford so Bradford's
bear in mind I've never been up to
Bradford in my life it kind of you know
we jvd on this um with 22 and Gio um and
it came about as so basically someone
was um they wasn't selling it as a deal
but they were trying to get rid of it
they had already Managed IT um they
showed us all their figures you they
showed us what they were earning things
like that so we thought oh you know what
this is quite a good deal we done a due
diligence on it we thought it was a
fantastic deal so we decided to take it
on um you know we had it for about 3
months so when we take took it on you
know for the first two months we was
making good money and then all of a
sudden we got a call from the council
and the council had basically said that
the landlords hadn't um applied for plan
of permission to turn it into five
one-bedroom Flats it was originally two
houses mhm so the cats were on were on
our ass for it after we said this to the
landlords he tried to deny it it just
went really downhill for us so we
decided to get out of it there were
other problems as well weren't there
with that problem because I remember at
the accelerate coaching performance
program when you spent two days at my
house and we're going through all your
finances looking at you had this one
little gem which was your prop which was
almost having to subsidize yeah it was
paying Bradford yeah so why was Bradford
losing money just because of the
planning issue because I would I can see
why that's a pain and it's hatle but why
was it losing money it was losing money
because you know we wasn't able to get
all the rooms filled out yeah time so
some months we would have you know three
rooms fully occupied and two would be
empty um but obviously where we was
quite new to this sort of strategy
taking on five in one building we didn't
realize what could happen and what the
pros and cons really were right um have
you gone on to do blocks or have you
just gone off it no um I mean I probably
will in the future but you think you bit
off more than you could Chew in an area
that you weren't familiar with yeah it
was far away from you you didn't have
the experience didn't know the area at
all and I I remember and I might be
wrong but you were very rant on people
like you didn't know anything I was like
when did you ask go I haven't been no oh
you've never been okay um but you just
didn't have a clue what was happening
with it and I think that was your
experience be in mind you were brand new
to the game now obviously it's a whole
different story now I bet you could take
that same property on I actually make it
profitable I probably could yeah I mean
um it was a great lesson learned I'm I
wouldn't say you know I've had bad deals
but there's not any deal that I regret
because yeah I would have learned from
it did you end up losing money over the
Bradford or did did it wash his face
yeah we end up losing about two grand
okay so it's not the end of the world
it's like a training course you know you
paid two grand you learn a load of stuff
it didn't work out but now you've gone
on to to be where you're at you know
what were the lessons from Bradford
don't invest in an area you don't really
know nothing about right um and like you
said before don't buy off more than you
can choose
just cuz you've got one deal and it's
going really well don't think I I take
five on now did you doubt the entire
rent to rent business model did you
think maybe I've just got lucky off of
this one property maybe this doesn't
work maybe I should quit I always knew
it would work especially after getting
my first and seeing everyone else in the
academy you know succeeding from their
enter rent deals I always knew it would
work but it was just finding my time of
when it would work obviously that first
one was working great and you know the
second one not so great but then after
that we've had a great
what about if the Bradford deal had been
your very first what about if You' have
paid somebody a sourcing fee that' have
got you these five properties in
Bradford you're really excited and then
it tanks loses money nightmare nightmare
could that have scarred you for life and
you still be in the uh still be a
full-time Carpenter with no properties
yeah it would have scared me for life
but I think I would have kept going yeah
but my second one would have been you
know something a bit more close to home
bit more cheaper rent um something a bit
more you know suitable so and and the
thing is both properties
is some will perform some will
overperform and some will underperform
and even if you do all the right things
there's always going to be some
properties in your portfolio that might
not perform as well as others that's
just kind of the nature of investing
yeah yeah all right so what happened
after that then so once you got rid of
your Bradford deals was it Lea did you
feel like oh yeah it was a big it was a
big weight off our shoulders so after we
got out of Bradford's
um obviously we went from technically
having six SA so he back down to one now
we started thinking you know we need to
get some more deals closer to home so
there when we started investing into
sorry we took on S in Epsom Kingston um
another one in Chelsea Hampton Colt um
and since then they they've just been
killing it I'm so glad to hear that do
you remember what happened to acpp
because I'm pretty sure at that program
that was where you were in that slight
predicament and just getting rid of your
Bradford deals yeah I remember um you
going and obviously explaining my
stories and you just said like you just
need to you know forget about Bradfords
that's that's past now but just get on
with it and keep expanding keep moving
forwards cuz you can't flug a dead horse
can you no sometimes if you're spending
80% of your time focusing on a bad deal
it's like you know what just cut that
bad deal yeah so rebuilding that
portfolio then how are you finding anals
now your first one you got lucky because
it landed on your lap the second one was
a disaster what systems have you found
now to actually find these deals and
build where are you finding them so we
we like to try and find them direct to
vendor um you know they're easy to
negotiate a lot of the time what we
offer is you know say for example um the
rent is 1500s um we will say look we
will actually give you um pretty much a
full Reverb or very high spec Reverb if
you can reduce that rate by maybe a few
hundred quid or you know four 500 quids
yeah and that seems to have worked
obviously being from the building
background um I kind of use them skills
to you know do these refurbs at a very
cheap rate yeah whereas you know it
might cost me three grand to make this
place look nice but it might cost
someone else 10 15 grand that's kind of
what we do and that's a big PLL for the
landlord yeah 100% that's how we've got
most of our recent properties what about
upfront rent deposits all that stuff
yeah we still pay deposits and up front
rent if we're doing a referb we normally
ask for a grace period for example we
took one on a Kingston we asked for a
7-Day Grace which he gave us and then as
soon as we picked up the keys me and my
partner we was we was there seven days
in a row from about 7:00 a.m. in the
morning to about 2:00 in the morning
grafting getting this Bas done yeah
that's quite generous though the fact
that you're giving a deposit just a
weeks grace period to not pay rent where
you're refurbishing the property and
you're refurbing the land loss property
yeah you know how much rent then to talk
me through one of the as a case study
talk me through one of these latest rent
events that you've done I'll talk you
through this Kingston one for example um
so the the rental original rental price
was 1500s I negotiated it down to 1200s
good um we spent I think was two grand
on a refurb and 12,200 pound on
Furnishings yeah so that's you know 32
in and literally after our 7 Days Grace
we had it on the market and then we've
been probably about 85 90% occupancy
solid um we made two grand profit last
month on that one solid and that's a one
bedroom flat what do you find works
better houses or flats Flats have only
ever dealt with Flats um I haven't dealt
with houses um as of yet mainly because
the areas that we're going in house
prices and house rental prices are you
know quite extortionate yeah so I feel
like for me Flats work better less
maintenance as well when you're
contacting the landlords then what are
you saying because there's a lot of
resistance to rent to rents yeah because
landlords maybe they might hear one
Horror Story of someone that did it bad
didn't get the right training didn't do
it properly and there as a result but
the thing that gets me is some landlords
or some agents will go oh there was a
bad experience with if a company let
rent to rent therefore we won't do it
anymore but what about all the bad
experiences you have with with tenants
tenants yeah you're going go oh we
rented to a family and it didn't go well
we don't rent the families anymore
that's ridiculous yeah you just need to
vet the family make sure that you you
know you learn from it in the same way
with a company L yeah there are some
people that do it wrong and there are
some people that mess up and don't pay
the land rent and end up having to get
evicted yeah but there are also some
people that do it really well and have
correct contracts do it properly so how
do you differentiate yourself when you
sp landlords from the the wannabe Trier
that's going to just be a time waster
and mess everybody around versus I'm
actually we're professionals we know
what we're doing how do you how do you
portray that and get that across um
first of I'd say it's all about trust
and obviously giving landlord that extra
bit of security um a lot of time when
I'm you know speaking to our landlords I
actually like to meet them face to face
go for a coffee I think sometimes when
you speak to a landlord over the phone
they they like to put you know a face to
a voice yeah and also when you meet them
and you go for coffee it goes gives you
that bit like of a personal touch yeah
and then from there you can say look um
you know if they've had a bad experience
you can basically say you know we've got
x amount of properties this is you know
if you want to speak to other landlords
that we've dealt with in the past um
things like that just to give them that
bit of you know bit of assurance makes
sense what do you say on the initial
call then because you have to to get a
cof with them you have to get copy with
them you know so you're calling them
cold you found them on oh yeah so I'd
find them for example on open rent about
hi just come across your property on
open rent um I just wonder if it's still
available um they'd say yeah um i' say
look I'm interested in book and a
viewing um they'd say great what's your
you know what's your situation and I'd
say look I've got an accommodation
company we basically rent our properties
to uh professionals a lot of
international relocators and then
basically go on to saying that you know
we can cover maintenance if it needs a
referb we're happy to provide a referb
um and so on and then from there they
would you know they would I say you know
I'm not interested or you know I'm
actually that sounds quite good
especially with a referb and then from
there I'd say look do you want to meet
up for a
coffee and then the and then you take
for a coffee and then the rest is
history yeah pretty much pretty much do
you think that now when you're ringing
LL Lords you're really confident in your
services and because you're sold it's
easy to sell the service whereas maybe
when you starting out you were kind of
thinking oh I'm not really sure what I'm
doing and I don't know so you weren't
sold I think it was just where I didn't
really when I first started I didn't
really know what to say and how to
handle these objections but obviously as
times can I hit some objections at you
and see what you would say yeah sure I
put you on the spot right now but all
right so I'll be I'll be the landlord
yeah so sorry so who's actually going to
be living in the property so it wouldn't
be myself it's actually going to be my
company that's going to be renting it
from you we accommodate you know
contractors professionals uh and a lot
of international
relocators okay yeah and what what's
your company called um a company is
called A+ properties we've been trading
for so over a year now um we've taken on
13 properties in the past year and we're
forever expand in our portfolio all
right uh it sounds interesting I'm not
sure though I mean I was thinking just
to rent it to a family so I'm not really
sure um I've heard some you know bad
experiences about company lets and yeah
I mean I'm not going to say all
companies are great you can get bad
experiences with companies but you can
also get bad experiences with tenants
that's why with a company we have no
tenant rights so you know if we for
example don't pay your rent you can
pretty much take take that your property
straight away okay yeah it sounds
interesting would you be able to have
references provide you with references
from other landlords and agents that
we've dealt with um I can provide you a
personal guarantors if that's something
you're open to okay yeah well um yeah
all right so what did you want to do um
how about we meet up for a coffee on
Saturday are you free at um 9:00 yeah
yeah 9:00 can do so do you not actually
book a view in then I would book a view
in and also go for a coffee interesting
so you don't just ring up and say Hey I
want to book a view in it depends cuz
some landord will say oh actually can we
just meet at the property or you know
yeah let's meet up first and then go
from there and then what do you say then
when you have a let's say you do a
viewing and you have a coffee let's say
you look around the property it's an
apartment what are you looking for what
are you wanting to see in that property
to how do you determine if it's going to
work as a good rent to rent or not first
of all it's location and also whenever I
go into a property
I look to see if for example if I'm
doing a refurb I look to see you know
what need's doing how much is it going
to cost me if it's if I know it's going
to cost me quite a bit of money I
probably wouldn't go for it yeah if it's
going to cost you 5 10 grand if it's
going to be a couple Grand maybe one or
two grand then great yeah but a lot of
time from photos I can pretty much so
location and and and and condition fine
what else are you looking at what are
the key things you're looking to see if
this could work because surely you can't
just rent any apartment in the entire
country and it would work brilliantly as
a rent to rent it has to fit a criteria
it's got to have a demand you know right
you got to know who your proper is gonna
be for who you target right so you're
going to be thinking okay is this going
to be contractors relocators tourists
you're going to do research you're going
to go on maybe property Intel airdna the
different sites yeah work out how much
potential Revenue this could bring in
what the running cost would be yeah how
much the landlord wants and ultimately
what you can offer yeah pretty much
pretty much and like I said obviously
you got to try and find who your target
audience is and obviously when I first
started I in my head I just thought us
only of tourist that stay in Airbnb
really yeah a lot of people think that
yeah but when you actually start you
know having your own airbnbs you
actually realize that you know it's not
it's not really tourists that are
staying it a lot of them are
professionals and a lot of them are
relocators I very rarely have tourist in
mine yeah that's so true so what is a
relocator a relocator would be if
someone's just purchased a house and
there's a chain and they need somewhere
temporary to live for you know an x
amount of months means you can provide
it to them cuz you know they can't rent
it from a state agent for less than 6
months so that's why we kind of bridge
the gap and the good thing about
relocators is often they'll stay for
quite a long time weren't they they're
going to stay for a few weeks or a few
weeks can even drag on a bit and it can
be a couple of months especially if
they've got for example a build going on
on their new property and a you know the
builds you know going over yeah so
you're charging a nightly amount they're
paying you you're paying the landlord
and you're just keeping the profit yeah
yeah minus cleaning fees and things like
that but yeah and how much profit after
cleaning fees and everything would you
say is average for one of your rent to
rents BR about Grands about Grand profit
yeah and you're also selling deals as
well you're selling you're you're
finding rent to rents for other Academy
members and you're introducing them as a
package deal and you're selling them
yeah how much do you sell a deal for on
average uh three Grands on average for a
deal you're selling about did you say a
a few a month yeah I sell about three
three Deals a month on average obviously
some months uh hire and more some months
we might sell five or six deals and some
deals we might sell two deals so how do
you find the time to be selling deals to
be running your own properties and
you're also you're still working
fulltime yeah still working fulltime on
my roof and the carp Dr business and is
that your business yeah that's my
business yeah nice um learning what I've
learned from the academy I've kind of
put it into my building business as well
okay so how' you mean just you know
running things properly getting things
systemized making sure you know you're
on top with you know your admin and work
out your you know your figures and
things like that yeah and I guess as
well a lot of what you learn on the
academy is basically business isn't it
yeah it's business structure hiring
staff systemizing things it also changes
your mindset and just your outlook on
life I believe or for me anyway when did
you joined the Academy I joined the
academy October 2022 how did you get the
money to do it uh I actually got a loan
from the bank so you got the loan were
you scared yeah yeah cuz it's a big deal
bro like getting a loan
to pay for Education where if it doesn't
work you've got nothing it's a big
investment yeah 100% how did you justify
that investment it actually took me so I
came to the crash course and then paid I
think it was two grand to do the rent of
rent training and then after that it
took me about three days after finishing
the live training to think you know I'm
going to join the academy yeah because I
thought I've done the rental rent
training but you know you got to be in
the room with people you know you you
need that help the mentoring yeah yeah
that's what it is the network yes it's
the the Network's crazy has it been a
good investment are you glad you did it
it's probably been the best investment
I've ever made in my life that's awesome
I'm glad to hear that what's been the
highlight then for you of the last 12
months the Highlight for me it's just
seeing yourself go from literally zero
to 100 um you know at the start of the
year I wasn't making nothing in property
and I wrote a gold down I was like you
know what by the end of the year I want
to be making four grand passive income
I've doubled that and it's just crazy to
think and sometimes I've just got to
pinch myself and look back and be like
this this is this is actually real yeah
you know what are the key things would
you say the key lessons that you've
learned that you'd pass on to somebody
that was just getting started just go
for it you know don't be scared to take
risk because you never know what could
happen money will always return so if
you're scared to make that first initial
investment you just need to go for it
and you know you could you can
potentially make it really big if you
put the work in yeah tell me a little
bit about what happened when you joined
the academy cuz we started the academy
boxing talk to me about that yeah so
that was um that was great fun it was
just nice to obviously you know do
business as well as box especially like
with you and the other Academy members
um we spot many times bro yeah we used
to have a really good spa wouldn't what
it would be and then obviously I my
fight Rob Moore and then Rob Moore some
of his team and crew and key members and
that wanting to fight you and the team
so you fought one of his guys and what
happened
um got the W as expected yeah but no
that was a fantastic night and obviously
you know just the training in general
and you know at at the end day it was
keeping me on top of things it was
keeping me focused it was keeping me
focused on business my training it was
just yeah it was great good night that
was 2,000 people there yeah that was an
epic night yeah so what's next then for
you so what's what's the plan then over
the next 12 months this last 12 months
you've been doing deal sourcing rent of
rents you've built up a nice portfolio
what's the plan moving forward um so
safe
2024 um is you know to keep expanding
the um service accommodation business
but as well as that we're looking at um
potentially taking on a development deal
uh so that's what we're looking at doing
maybe jump into the BR game you know
with my skills I think that be that' be
really good strategy for me absolutely
but it's just you know taking things
step by step I don't want to take on too
many things at once yeah what would be
your I guess your final words of advice
and wisdom for people listening that
want to kind of do what you've done
starting out out no experience not loads
and loads of money you start putting
into deposits and stuff what would you
say would be the key step You' say to
people starting out uh if people
starting out I would say you know if
you're watching this video just sign up
to his one pound crash course go from
there and you know you could be sitting
in this in this chair next year
absolutely well dude it's been a real
pleasure thank you so much for coming
down to come win us on a Wednesday if
you want to come and join me at the 1
property investors crash course I will
leave a link in the description it's
literally end the day with me and the
team no catch Link in description be
there and I'll see you guys next time